[Music]
[Applause]
Ryan Costello covers the Jets for the
New York Post and he joins us now when
did you know that this was probably the
end for Aaron Rodgers Brian
probably Dan when they brought the cart
to take him from the medical tent to the
locker room which is about 25 to 30
yards so that it tells you he couldn't
walk that distance you don't usually see
them car you know I see guys carved off
the field you don't usually see the car
to the medical tent so once that happens
you know I thought it was bad
how would you describe the atmosphere
prior to that
I was electric I mean it was incredible
I I can't remember a Jets game ever
having an atmosphere like that before
the game uh maybe maybe Rex Ryan's first
game against the Patriots at Giant
Stadium but nothing at MetLife was like
that it was you know the Jets did a
great job with the lights were out they
had all these Dale everyone had a
bracelet on that lit up and the the
place Method Man was introducing them
and they call her coming out with the
American flag I mean it was crazy it was
a really electric atmosphere any news
this morning any updates no nothing yet
he's had an MRI I'm not sure what time
I'm sure we'll find out later this
morning but I mean they there's not much
hope here um you know my understanding
is a doctor
feels your your ankle and they can tell
if the Achilles is intact and this is
just kind of a formality to make make
sure but so I don't think there's much
hope for anything here but we'll
probably find out later this morning for
sure okay what are the options as the
Jets move forward
well I think Zach Wilson is you know
he's the guy right now they've got a
game in Dallas on Sunday there's nothing
they can do right now
um so he he's the guy and
look they've been building towards Zach
Wilson having a second act I don't think
they ever thought it was going to come
now but this is the what they've been
working on they decided not to get rid
of him this off season kind of keep him
and try to rebuild his confidence have
Rogers work with him so he's the guy for
now and I think they'll see if they can
win some games riding their defense in
their running game and managing around
him sort of like what they did last year
in the middle of the year and then if if
you know if it's not looking good maybe
then they explore other options but
right now I think this is the Zach
Wilson show okay
do you place a call to Tom Brady laughs
I guess I guess he called Don Ying his
agent and and see I think it's a really
big long shot I I mean I can't even
fathom how you'd make that work salary
wise how you you know with the salary
cap well you know the quarterbacks are
not coming for six million dollars right
he Tom Brady is going to want a good
amount of money and you'd have to
completely just strip down the offense
and rebuild it uh you know that he
doesn't run the same offense as Aaron
Rodgers so I think that's a pipe dream
but yeah I mean I guess I guess you
could see if he's he's interested I
wondered did the Jets know what they
have in Jack Wilson
no they don't
um I think there's fingers crossed and
there's some hope and I do think he
handled all this pretty well uh over the
last eight months uh you know he he lost
his job and he embraced it and he seems
to have a good attitude and you know he
did some okay things during the
preseason but nothing that tells you
okay he's ready to be a different
quarterback right now
um you know I think I think you're gonna
see them manage around him Dan I thought
we saw that the in the fourth quarter
last night the end of the game you know
maybe you take a shot to the end zone
there it said it when you stand up for
that last field goal no shots to The End
Zone it was hand off hand off hand off
hand off hand off they were not letting
him throw the ball so you know if you
remember last year when the Jets got hot
in October Zach Wilson was the
quarterback and they figured out a way
to win and they rode their defense and
they rode Breeze Hall and I think
they're gonna try to do that again and
that will work for some of the time and
there's going to be some games where it
will not work at all and Dallas I mean
if Dallas plays like they did against
the Giants this past week this week this
week could be a tough one and you know
the Jets are going to struggle playing
from behind that that's where the
problem's gonna be and that's what Aaron
Rodgers was supposed to solve was they
weren't going to be behind number one
and then they always felt like they were
going to be in the fourth quarter with
Aaron Rodgers you're not going to feel
like that was Zach Wilson who had a
worse weekend the Giants or the Jets
who I say the Jets I mean because look
the Giants can say oh it's one week
we're moving on uh you know it's a long
season uh you don't overreact to week
one
I mean then everyone saw this publicly
you watched hard docs this entire
organization was built around Aaron
Rodgers this season the whole thing the
defensive coordinator Jeff Albrecht sat
there in the first episode of saying
this is our quarterback we can win with
this guy right and everything was about
Aaron Rodgers and that was gone in four
plays I mean it's just it's hard to even
wrap my brain around it right now and
I've been around the Jets a long time
I've seen a lot of bad Jetson things but
this one is tough to comprehend right
now this is why the Jets can't have nice
things Brian
I mean it's really just unbelievable Dan
and I think Jets fans would probably
describe me as pessimistic about the
Jets but even I could never have
foreseen four plays and a going like
this it's just incredible and you know
what he was under duress in three of
those four plays yeah you know Rhys Hall
had a really nice run but I I mean I was
worried right away when I'm going wait
they're just starting and they're
putting pressure on him and yeah even
when he got sacked I'm like did anybody
block anybody on that play
yeah it stopped look Dan the offensive
line was a concern all three training
camp you know we wrote about it we
talked about it
it's hard for me to pin this completely
on them the way it was explained to me
that play was supposed to be a quick
pass if you watch Dwayne Brown the left
tackle he Dives at Leonard Floyd's legs
it was a cup lock usually that's a cup
lock Quick Pass he didn't execute the
cup lock he didn't knock the guy to the
ground so he failed in that aspect but
it seemed like Rogers maybe I don't know
if the coverage forces but held onto the
ball a bit and then you know it just it
you know but you should be able to give
up a sack and not expect to lose your
quarterback for the season just
incredible
will they move to natural grass next
year that's a great question I just saw
DJ read their cornerback just tweeted
about it uh said you know it's time for
natural grass Randall Cobb was pretty
vocal in the locker room I know David
back to Yari put some stuff out there
last night on social media
uh that I mean that's I think that's an
NFL question more than the Jets even
right I I that stadium has a lot of use
between the two football teams there's
concerts there constantly I'm not smart
enough about Turf and grass to know how
that works but I I gotta think it'd be
difficult to maintain that field you
know ESPN last night highlighted what
the transition that field that went
under I think there was concerts there
there were sold out concerts there
Thursday sold out concert that Friday
Giants game Sunday night Jets game
Monday night that's an incredible amount
of use for a field then and so I I'm not
sure grass can sustain that
um you know so I I I don't know if they
can do that before I let you go we're
talking to Brian Costello covers the
Jets for the New York Post just trying
to figure out the recovery time for
Aaron Rodgers factoring in he's going to
turn 40 in December of coming back from
an Achilles have you had any information
on them yeah a little bit I I think you
know I the way I understand this is
surgery is immediate it'll be like this
week it's not it's not like an ACL where
you take some time before the surgery so
I think his surgery I think he'd be able
to probably throw
sometime in the spring and then you know
he'd be able to come back I think next
season it's week one so I think it's
about it you know it's about a year
usually they come back
the question is Dan he's gonna be 40
years old in December uh it's a tough
rehab and does he want to is he going to
want to undergo that rehab
you know you got to think is he gonna
not want to go out like this this is a
tough way I I he's obviously a very
prideful guy I gotta think he's gonna
he's not gonna want the ending of his
career to be like this but it's A Hard
Road back
I know you're busy thanks for joining us
Brian
thanks Dan Ryan Costello New York Post
beat writer for the Jets